this is a production of Cornell
University great thanks for the
introduction you need I guess I need to
apologize I realized on the way down the
elevator I switch the title around on
the poster says angstroms two acres if I
swish it makers hang sure we just do to
the presentation of the flow I'm gonna
start with my field soils and they move
more than my molecular level studies so
yeah in essence this is going to be an
overview of my dissertation work that's
broadly focused on the interaction of
soil organic matter with mineral
surfaces so a quick outline of what I'm
going to go over here I'm gonna come
right back round kind of explain why I'm
asking the questions that I'm asking now
I'm gonna show some results from some
field soils that I collected from
Pennsylvania I'm gonna wrap up with a
series of laboratory scale experiments
looking at model systems and hopefully
have some time for acknowledgments and
some really nice questions all right so
some quick background so soil organic
carbon and nitrogen represent really
important pools of carbon nitrogen on
the planet for reasons that have already
been covered extensively the semester in
the seminar series and one of the main
reasons is because soil organic matter
which contains carbon and nitrogen is
stabilized in soils and there are a few
really big known stabilization
mechanisms of soil organic matter in
soils one of which is physical occlusion
of soil organic matter so we take our
organic matter here and we surround it
with something like a mineral particles
or something like that so it's not
accessible from microbial breakdown
hence it is stabilized and remains in
the soil there's also this concept of
chemical recalcitrance where we have
these big kind of bulky hulking
molecules that are unwieldy to attack
enzymatically and they aren't
mineralized and ansar stabilized then
there's this last point that i'm going
to be talking primarily about and that
is this association of organic matter
with soil minerals and as Angela kind of
talked about a month or q ago this can
take on a few different forms one of
which is the co precipitation of organic
matter with soil minerals and the other
form is what I'm gonna be talking about
today primarily is the adsorption
of organic matter from solution onto
mineral surfaces there were soil
particles in various forms
so it dissolved organic matter if we
talking organic matter in solution we're
going to be talking about that is all
organic matter fraction and if you pick
up a soil science textbook and go back
to the glossary and look up his all's
organic matter or deal them you're going
to get a definition that's fairly
similar to this a mixture of soluble
organic materials derived from the
release end or partial decomposition of
plant and microbial residues I
underlined mixture there because I think
it's an exceptionally important point
here so dissolved organic matter readily
absorbs on mineral surfaces but it's a
mixture so not all components have a
tendency to adsorb equally there are
some factors that we know associated
with dissolve organic matter composition
have a pretty big impact on the
adsorption one of which is molecular
size are we looking at the absorption of
my favorite molecule here Gallic acid on
a mineral surface or are we looking at
it's more kind of polymerized complex
counterpart I don't know the name of
this but generally speaking this is
larger and dissolve organic matter
molecules that are larger have a
tendency to preferentially adsorb the
functionality so the functional group
composition of the organic matter is
also considered to be really important
and more specifically organics matter
that's enriched in functional groups
like aromatic phenolic and carboxylic
type groups are believed to play a
really important role in retention of
dissolved organic matter and last but
certainly not least is the elemental
composition of the organic matter itself
for the do am generally speaking do em
with carbon to nitrogen ratios on the
low side that is higher in nitrogen
relative to carbon is believed to
associate very strongly directly with
mineral surfaces so that could take the
form or something like this nice model
peptide here on the left but also
biomolecular constituents like this PT
toxin here on the right also would be
retained pretty strongly but as you
I tell from the title and and so many
other presentations this semester on
organic matter interactions with soils
this is a cross scale thing it's not
simply a molecular level issue so in
soils we have a lot of surface inputs of
dissolved organic matter either through
release or released actually by roots or
or through senescent plant material and
what happens is as this dissolved
organic matter enters the soil solution
it percolates downward through the soil
matrix where it's subsequently subjected
to a series of inputs and losted as it
moves through the profile and some of
the main inputs are released by biota we
can also see these origin and release of
dissolved organic matter back into the
solution and some of the the main losses
that we're aware of that we know that
occur in soils are this adsorption by
the soil matrix you can get uptake by
soil biota and we can also get the
precipitation of the organic matter with
minerals generally speaking as we move
down a profile the losses kind of went
out and we tend to see less dissolved
organic matter as we go down a profile
but I kind of had a question with this
so if we have DM inputs at the surface
and all these downstream processes going
on what happens if we take the surface
soil where you know the bulk of organic
matter is and we kind of invert it or we
disturb it as one might see and let's
say tillage and agricultural system what
does that do to all these downstream
processes that dissolve organic matter
in a soil profile and with that question
in mind I'm going to start showing some
results from some field studies that I
did looking at dissolved organic matter
dynamics in a [ __ ] cultural soil from
Pennsylvania so the specific field site
that I used is the penn state russell
larson egg Research Center in Rock
Springs Pennsylvania
I got working with these plots back when
I was still a baby a Penn State student
I wish I had a picture of me then you
guys wouldn't even be able to tell the
difference
and this field sites are located
basically smack dab in the middle of the
state of Pennsylvania right in the
absolutely gorgeous ridge and valley
province of PA and the nice big
limestone valley the plots that i used
are part of this tillage experiment that
was initiated back in 1978 so happy 40th
birthday tillage experiment plots these
are pretty long-term and they're I think
there were three or four different types
of
tillich treatments in these 24 plots by
focused only on two plots and and two
tillage treatments and those were the
no-till treatment and the the moldboard
tillage inist and these plots were
subjected to a moldboard disking to
about 20 centimetres every year in the
spring and something else I'd like to
point out is the sampling that I did
within these plots I sampled at a couple
different locations so there's this
access road here I cuts adjacent to the
plots I sampled that 125 feet 375 and
625 feet from that access road and the
sampling itself it looked like this so
we pulled three cores out of the ground
at each one of those sites and pulled
them forever and this is what the cores
looked like from the till plot and the
no-till plot we can see that the soil
we're working with here is kind of uh
well these aren't the best pictures but
this is what is called the Hagerstown
soil series and this is a fairly typical
alpha saw this was developed over
limestone residual I'm down in central
PA
it wasn't glaciated so these are fairly
old soils and if the lighting were a
little bit better and these cores
weren't ride you could really see at the
tilled soil what it's made up of is
basically a nice well-defined ap horizon
down the 20 centimeters followed by a
series of BT horizons as we move down
the profile and the no-till soil also
has an a horizon but it's more of a
gradual decrease into the BT horizons so
those cores I pull them again into three
and then I split them up into five
different depth increments and from
there I was interested in isolating and
characterizing the dissolved organic
matter so that was kind of the focus
this study was the d-line fraction so I
did a fairly standard um extraction
procedure I suspended the soil and water
out of one to ten L water ratio shook it
overnight pass it through a point two
micron filter and the subjected the
filtrate to a series of characterization
methods one of which is this total
organic carbon and nitrogen within the
do M fraction I did some optical
characterization with you Eva's
spectrophotometry so I looked at the
extent of aromatic functionalities
within your organic matter and then last
but certainly not least here I made some
fluorescence excitation emission
matrices of the organic matter samples
and I'll get more into what that means
as I get closer to working with them so
let's get a feel for the the bulk soils
themselves what kind of properties do
these have a soils are mildly acidic
they have a pH around six none of the
the samples deviated too far from that
kind of nice knowing that pH wouldn't be
a confounding factor here texturally the
soils kind of had a real silt rich
topsoil and became gradually finer as we
went down into the subsoil and the
mineralogy of these soils is kind of
interesting we have some alumina
silicate clays alight and kaolinite that
dominate the clay fraction and I also
did some extractions that show that
there's a decent amount of crystalline
iron oxides in the soil that might have
a pretty pretty big impact on the
surface reactivity of the mineral
particles so really
the bulk carbon-nitrogen distributions
of the soils here we kind of see the the
textbook trend that you would expect to
see with depth knowledge where the
surface layer is kind of modernized as
far as the carbon contents and nitrogen
contents is well are concerned followed
by a pretty precipitous drop-off in the
subsoil and this isn't the case for the
no-till soils where we kind of start off
generally with higher concentrations of
carbon and nitrogen and then we get more
of a gradual decrease as we would expect
in a system with less disturbance so the
dissolved organic matter itself kind of
follows a somewhat of a similar trend
where the organic matter in dissolve
fraction the contents I should say Orca
modernize within the plow layer we also
get this quick drop-off below that and
again no-till system it's more of a
gradual type decrease and this is true
for both the carbon and the nitrogen and
if we look at the carbon nitrogen ratios
of the dissolved organic fraction we can
see that generally speaking with depth
the c2n ratio goes up I present this
because I'm kind of going back to that a
concept of carbon nitrogen ratio playing
an influence in a selective absorption
of GOM so that's something to keep in
mind
so some of the optical characterization
now we're looking at the more molecular
composition of the organic matter this
is the specific UV absorbance at 2:54 we
can see that with both of these soils
there's a decrease in the Suva to 54
with depth suggesting that dissolved
organic matter becomes less aromatic in
the subsoils and similarly in addition
to the bulk and the dissolved organic
matter just raw content we see its
molecular composition of the dissolved
organic matter also the distribution is
influenced by a by tillage somewhat we
get a surface from aaj an ad again so
now I'm going to talk about dissolved
organic matter he fluorescence
excitation emission matrices these look
really scary but they're actually really
cool and I'm hoping to kind of convince
you of that
so dissolved organic matter samples
again they're complex so there's a lot
of stuff in these and one of the ways
that uh water and soil chemists like to
characterize this is using this
technique which basically probes the
fluorescence emission of the dissolved
organic matter sample at stepped
excitation wavelengths what happens is
doing this you can create an excitation
landscape or a fluorescence landscape I
guess I should say that's going to look
differently based on the molecular
composition and source of the dissolved
organic matter I'm not I like to
generally break it up in the two classes
one of which is the less condensed
aromatics so that is individual aromatic
structures within the dissolved organic
matter and this oftentimes takes on the
forms of things like aromatic proteins
like tryptophan or phenylalanine but
also nucleic acids and other organic
acids we'll also first similarly to
these there's also
so the more condensed aromatic so I'm
probably shooting myself in the foot
here I'm going to use the terms you make
and fulvic acid for those that do
organic matter research you know that's
like taboo but this is the term that
people use in the literature for
characterizing these types of structures
these are more condensed so they have
fuse aromatics so the fluorescence is
redshifted because the homo-lumo gap is
altered by that that's another story for
another time so if we look at it for
look at these maps for the dissolve
organic matter fractions that I isolate
from you this course you can see some
pretty cool trends going on here so one
that occurred at every single site and
in all these cores with depth is we see
a reduction and the the fluorescent
behavior that corresponds with core
condensed aromatics and that's with
depth those features are removed as we
go further down the profile and what
becomes relatively more pronounced are
these more microbial product type
fluorescence landscapes and one last
thing I'd like to point out is yet again
tillage really kind of punctuated this
transition quite a bit so yeah so those
are the main points I wanted to kind of
get to you with these with that I'm
gonna summarize my field based work so
in addition to the known kind of
textbook trends in bulk carbon nitrogen
content of to a no-till soils we see
that is all organic matter content
reflects that where we see the surface
homogeneity within the plow layer
followed by a quick drop off in the
tilled system and more of a slow kind of
gradual decline where there's no tillage
being utilized as for the
characteristics of the dissolved organic
matter they follow a pretty similar
trend with that surface heterogeneity a
quick punctuation of the trends and we
see that we look at the molecular
characteristics of the dissolved organic
matter their carbon to nitrogen ratio
increases with depth aromaticity goes
down with depth and the presence of more
condensed aromatic structures goes down
with depth and this kind of has the
fingerprint of selective adsorption of a
GOM as it percolates throughout the
profile these features in and of
themselves do but this little hitch here
has me thinking a little bit differently
because
soluble micro
products things like proteins nucleic
acids tend to adsorb pretty readily in
soils as well which makes me wonder if
perhaps lower in these soil profiles
where we have high reactive mineral
surface area and very little organic
carbon if the biota that are down there
are perhaps releasing things into the
soil solution that might be kind of
dominating the dynamic down there as
opposed to selective absorption so with
this kind of high reactive mineral
surface area a protein nucleic acid
mindset I'm going to jump in out of my
laboratory studies looking at the
interactions of biomolecules with
mineral surfaces so a little bit one
more quick piece of background I'm sure
you guys have seen this model before I
think Angela showed it during her talk
this is a model that was proposed by
Markus Kleber and associates about
decade ago and they kind of constructed
this hypothetical model here to help
explain some of the multi-layer organic
matter associations we see in soil
profiles and they've built off of this
observation that biomolecules interact
strongly with mineral surfaces and in
this model the multi-layer formation is
hinging upon the presence of this
contact that is supposedly a biomolecule
rich directly at the mineral surface the
biomolecule rich later excuse me that
forms when biomolecules adsorbed
directly on the mineral surface undergo
conformational rearrangements and then
more organic matter can adsorb on top of
them forming the multi layers leading to
stabilization in this multi layered type
architecture so biomolecules are really
important believed to be important for
that reason and also one thing I'd like
to point out is the conformational
rearrangements or believed to make this
all possible
so we're also really important and I'll
talk more about the conformation in a
bit so to probe's this question
experimentally in the lab by utilized a
few models use a model protein a bovine
serum albumin and I used a model DNA so
the protein I use a bovine serum albumin
is a globular protein and it has a
secondary structure that is largely
composed of alpha helixes that's these
kind of these really tightly wound
regions sure
these are connected by these long
extended chains that are more extended
in open type structures there are also
some more internalized term type
elements there as well and the DNA that
was use comes from herring testes this
is kind of a standard physical chemical
model for a DNA experiment
it's a double-stranded be form of DNA
and this when you pick up a bottle of
herring testis DNA what's in there it's
kind of long it's you get a really long
size distribution of DNA right out of
the bottle so what I did is I decided
I'm going to share this to a known size
because size can be an important factor
looking at absorption by wooden to share
it to a known just known size with a
relatively tight size distribution to
eliminate that as an influencing factor
here and for both these biomolecules I
think it's important to point out that
under my experimental conditions of five
milli molar KCl background at pH 5 these
biomolecules are both going to have a
negative charge on them it's a net
negative charge both will still have
regions of positive charge so I used two
different model mineral surfaces one of
which is potassium saturated
montmorillonite
I use good old swy tube at night for
those that have worked with this before
it's a lot of fun this is a two-to-one
aluminosilicate clay mineral meaning it
has two of these tetrahedral units or
layers I should say as shown by this
brownish color and one octahedral sheet
as shown here by the gray the gray layer
and this specific montmorillonite is
bentonite has a permanent negative
structural charge that's situated in
that central octahedral layer and that
imparts a certain shrink swell behavior
to this clay that gives it a really nice
higher reactive surface area and unlike
the montmorillonite i used another
mineral called ger tight named after the
german poet and hobby geologist Goethe
that is an iron oxyhydroxide
unlike the montmorillonite this is not
negatively charged this is positively
charged at the pH values use but similar
to the mom Roland I it has a very high
reactive surface area as one could
predict from looking at the mineral
structure so this is an SEM image of the
minerals that I used in my experiments
you can tell you're quite small
they range from maybe a few hundred
nanometers up to a couple of microns in
length and they're very very thin so
they have a nice high reactive service
area again we're looking at biomolecule
absorption to a couple different
surfaces here biomolecules are kind of
complicated to study the surface
behavior of so like other molecules that
absorb the surfaces they have adsorption
rate constants that can be informative
about the process they have equilibrium
surface coverages that can also be
informative about the process and they
have this tendency to undergo
conformational adjustments as I kind of
alluded to earlier and ideally when
we're going to study the adsorption
we're gonna be able to capture all these
things we're gonna be able to do so
without having to drive the system which
could artificially change the
confirmation we're gonna do so without
making a system get too hot too salty
or anything else that's gonna make it
kind of artificially conformed so to do
this I use a technique known as Institue
attenuated total reflectance Fourier
transform infrared spectroscopy say that
110 times fast or ATR FTIR and this is a
form of vibrational spectroscopy as you
can probably tell from looking at those
cheesy little cartoons right there but
what separates this from other forms of
vibrational spectroscopy like
traditional infrared is this ATR part so
this has what's called an internal
reflective element in which the infrared
light is shined into this internal
reflective element we have a diamond one
and it's reflected off and as its
reflected it's not a totally efficient
reflection as nothing truly is so we get
this loss of energy upon reflection that
is propagated perpendicularly from the
surface of this diamond that allows us
to use it as a sampling surface
basically and what I did for my
experiments is I coated the diamond in a
mineral film and watched as the
biomolecules adsorbed to the surface
using this technique I was able to get
adsorption kinetic data equilibrium
surface coverage stuff some mechanistic
conformational information and I was
able to do this in solution so I don't
have to worry about confounding factors
there either
so with that I'm going to move on to
some of my studies looking at the
association of the protein BSA with the
clay montmorillonite so this is an
infrared spectrum of DSA and it has
three features you're going to typically
see an F G IR spectra of proteins has
the M at one two and three Peaks that
correspond with backbone vibrations on
the protein and in my studies I'm going
to show results from the Hammad one in
two regions so the one M at one region
contains all of the structural info so
that's where I'm going to look and say
hey the protein is unfolding or not M
into this is gonna be my quantifying
region for BSA adsorption on the surface
and what's shown here is kind of a time
series of BSA on the clay surface so as
the BSA adsorbs to give a higher and
higher and higher signal and when we go
ahead and plot our amma to peak here
against time we can look at our
adsorption kinetics and for the four
different concentrations used in this
study you can see that the adsorption
kinetics follow a certain logarithmic
time dependence and that suggests that
the energetic barrier is associated with
adsorption are heterogeneous so it's not
a single activation energy here it's a
distribution of energies and it's not
entirely evident just from these curves
but I'll show why I believe this later
this is likely attributable to
continuous protein rearrangement on the
surface protein lateral interactions
with other adsorbed proteins or
potentially electrostatic heterogeneity
so we look at our equilibrium surface
coverage results we can see that they're
fit reasonably well by this black line
here this is the the classic Langmuir
adsorption isotherm and the main thing i
want to point out here is you know this
model has a built in K value which
corresponds with the kind of the
affinity or the strength of the
adsorption and if you look at this
number here 5.9 seven times ten to the
fifth that's a pretty big number so the
protein as we are kind of already more
or less new adsorbs really strongly to
the clay surface
there absorbs and the kinetics are
logarithmic what about the structure the
conformation I keep talking about that
what what does that look like so if we
first consider here the native secondary
structure of the BSA as shown by these
dotted lines you see again it's
primarily off gila sees with some more
extended chains and turns kind of mixed
into the secondary structure but we look
at the secondary structure of the BSA on
montmorillonite
you see that a few things are happening
here and primarily I'd like to draw your
attention to this lowest concentration
in corresponding surface coverage at
this value
it seems that VSA indeed unfolds and we
see an increase in these expanded kind
of extended chains and turn type
structures that are more open and this
comes at the expense of more condensed
alpha helical regions but interestingly
as we look at the BSA adsorbed at higher
concentrations and surface coverages it
starts to look more and more like native
BSA in terms of its secondary structure
so these values are all from equilibrium
so that's the very end of my experiments
question is does the protein it's Orban
this way and stay there or is it adsorb
and kind of flop around and find the
energetically most favorable state on
the mineral surface and to address this
question I use a technique known as 2d
correlation spectroscopic analysis and
I'm not going to get into the details of
this right now but if you guys have any
questions about it I would love love
love love to talk about it this is
fascinating and this technique makes use
of what is known as a synchronous and
asynchronous plot to look at sequential
changes to the protein structure with
adsorption time and when we apply this
analysis to the data that I have we see
that there are at least two different
conformational pathways that we can see
one is that this lowest BSA
concentration or the protein adsorbs and
with time we see an increase in open
structures here and the loss of the more
compact alpha helixes at the higher BSA
concentrations the sequence looks a
little bit different you see that as the
protein is on the surface we actually
see an increase in aggregated strands so
that is kind of inter molecular
structures
so a higher surface coverage is that
kind of makes sense have more neighbors
hmm we see a decrease in these more open
turns and extended chains with time so
there are two pathways that occurring
there one where the BSA it's orbs it
becomes more open another one where it
absorbs and becomes more compact and
internalized with time so I'm gonna
quickly summarize this here at the one
thing is evident from these studies BSA
does absorb pretty strongly on clay but
we already kind of knew that as a
scientific community but this really
demonstrated though is that not only as
a confirmation change but it's a dynamic
confirmation on the surface and as a
dynamic pathway that differs based on
the surface coverages themselves we're
at the lowest VSA concentrations use the
BSA's orbs it opens up at the higher
concentrations at its orbs and becomes
more aggregated so now I'm going to move
on to some more studies that I've done
with BSA and DNA this time on another
mineral surface it's the ger tied to
more needle looking things before I do
that I'm going to quickly show an FTIR
spectrum of DNA this is a vibrational
spectrum of DNA and solution and similar
to the protein we see some vibrational
modes that are attributable to backbone
vibrations so we have the phosphodiester
groups from these phosphonate groups or
phosphodiester groups here stretching
asymmetric and symmetric modes and we
also have some carbon oxygen and carbon
carbon stretching from the backbone
showing up as well and similar to the a
mid to of protein I use this backbone
carbon-carbon stretching mode as my
quantifier for DNA adsorption I've
verified this using another technique so
it's it's good to go so some of the
results here start off with the BSA
first thing I'd like to point out I'm
now working on units of mass base
concentration rather than molarity to
make the correspondence between the
protein and DNA a little bit easier we
can see the kinetics here look a little
bit different than a denim Amarone
especially at the lower concentrations
used wherein we have this kind of
mudal logistic type curve correspond to
these adsorption kinetics there's this
lag phase that these this connects have
built into it and then the protein
literature with surface absorption this
lag phase is a correspond with a kind of
cooperative clustering effect of the
protein on the surface where the
kinetics are really really slow until we
get a certain base layer surface
coverage in which case it really kind of
starts to take off you notice when we go
to higher concentrations that isn't
quite as apparent DNA on the other hand
these are the adsorption kinetics for
DNA encore tight they kind of follow a
classic first-order adsorption meaning
the the adsorption is rate limited by
energetic barriers as opposed to mass
transfer or some kind of a clustering
effect and furthermore as a single
energetic barrier it's not a range again
we look at the equilibrium isotherms
here
so both BSA and DNA have pretty good
high affinity isotherms here as you can
tell from the shapes of the curve but
it's pretty apparent we look at the
affinity coefficients that come out of
the Langmuir equation here that DNA
tends words were quite a bit more
strongly actually that's something I'll
kind of link in the next slide or two to
the structure of the adsorb DNA so the
conformation what happens to the
conformation is it like montmorillonite
where we see unfolding well I think the
trends are fairly similar it looks like
the lowest concentration of BSA used we
see something quite similar where we see
an unfolding of the BSA and opening up
of extended chains at the expense of
more condensed alpha helix C's at the
higher concentration is used we can see
that again it looks more like native BSA
similar to the mom ruolan i
for DNA we see some we can excuse me we
can see some very clear direct evidence
that there's bond formation between DNA
and the go tight one piece of evidence
is these XPS spectra here so I'm not
going to get into the details of XPS in
essence this peak shift here about point
seven electron volts for the phosphorous
spectrum is in line with what you'd see
for like a phosphate adsorption on Farah
hydrate or something which corresponds
really clearly with an inner sphere of
coordination between this phosphodiester
group on the backbone in the ger tight
surface if we look at the infrared
spectra of DNA adsorbed in in solution
we can see further evidence for direct
inner sphere coordination so in solution
there's kind of this valley here between
these Peaks and when DNA adsorbs we get
this nice big peak pops up at ten
hundred and ten wave numbers and if you
look in the literature here this
corresponds really strongly with
computational studies that have shown
that there's most likely an iron oxygen
phosphorus stretching bond forming there
and further evidence for this is if we
look at higher energies at the
asymmetric stretching modes of the
backbone phosphodiester group we see a
shift of about seven or eight wave
numbers upon it sorption to a lower
energy and interestingly this shift here
could also be indicative the
conformational change of DNA from the B
form that initially started in to a more
expanded a optically different Z form
but if we look elsewhere in the spectrum
of DNA we don't see any of the other
indicators at a z form has indeed popped
up
suggesting that the DNA adsorbs in the B
form and doesn't necessarily undergo any
conformational changes but we do get
this inner sphere bond forming so to
quickly wrap this up
both PSA and DNA do adsorb strongly on
go type there are some differences in
the kinetics BSA at the low
concentrations has this kind of lag
phase where as DNA is just straight-up
first-order all the way conformational e
it looks like BSA again does kind of
unfold on these surfaces at lower
concentrations at least or surface
coverages whereas a higher surface
coverage is not so much for DNA no large
kind of long order conformational change
seems to occur at being said there is an
inner sphere bond that appears to occur
between the backbone phosphodiester
group and the ger tight surface and this
is a really nice strong stable bond and
that's the angst room component of this
work so got to highlight that so there
is a direct bond forming there so what
happens when we mix them together in
solution and which look and see how they
absorb when they're together I mean one
could very easily build up the argument
based on the kinetic results where
there's that lag phase in the protein
and the equilibrium isotherms where we
have this real nice higher affinity with
the DNA you could easily say we're gonna
put them both together and DNA is gonna
preferentially adsorb on the surface
well I don't want to spoil anything too
much but when you mix molecules together
in solution have a tendency to undergo
what is called super molecular assembly
and this is really important for two
reasons one of the main reasons is as
molecules in solution spontaneously
assemble to form these aggregates the
properties of the Constituent
biomolecules change a lot and it's very
interesting to see how that could
possibly translate to the surface
behavior at the mineral surface and
there haven't been too many studies
leading up to this that I've
demonstrated anything and one more thing
that's really important about this is we
know we've known for decades actually a
super molecular assembly does occur in
dissolve organic matter amongst those
components so it has a more than a wee
bit of environmental relevance as well
so for these studies what I did is I
made a series of super molecular
complexes and these are made by using a
fixed DNA concentration and it was
titrated with different amounts of
protein in solution and once these
complexes are formed a character I is
the extent to which they bind how
strongly do they associate I
characterized the charge characteristics
of the complex is relative to the
constituent biomolecules and I look at
the complex as you fellows and I said
hey how are you guys interacting with
each other i characterized that as well
so looking at some of the
here this is kind of the extent of
binding here on the left hand side this
is an equilibrium binding curve between
protein and DNA as derived from a
technique called circular dichroism and
there are two main things I'd like to
draw your attention to here one of which
is this the shape of the binding curve
again it has that S shape that we saw
for the kinetics of protein adsorption
and this suggests that there are some
cooperativity amongst the proteins bound
to the DNA so when one adsorbs or binds
it's more likely to make further binding
more favourable and one other thing here
is this the binding saturation is
reached on the DNA at a protein DNA
ratio of about 15 so at this point when
we add more protein to the system it's
not binding directly to the DNA because
we've reached a saturation on the DNA
helix itself so and I'd the K value that
comes out of this is really high it's on
the order of five or six times 10 to the
fifth I didn't put it up here because
it's not quantitatively useable because
it's actually a strong underestimate of
the real case but it is it's proof that
this binding is quite strong we see the
charge characteristics of the complexes
are fairly unique as well we're starting
with DNA that has a relatively high
electro phoretic mobility so that means
it has a large negative charge on it BSA
is up here just below zero so it's not
quite as negative it's just got a little
bit of negative charge this pH there you
can see that as we combine them and make
complexes of mixed BSA DNA ratios the
negative charge in the complexes goes
down so we change the charge
characteristics here as well so how does
these complexes interact in solution
this is where a technique known as
dynamic light scattering comes in this
is a set of light scattering curves here
by scattering distributions where we
have relaxation time on the x axis
arbitrary intensity on the y axis and
what we have here is DNA with increasing
amounts of BSA added to the system and
BSA by itself and there's two main
features I'd like to draw your attention
to on these relaxation time
distributions one is the fast mode the
fast relaxation mode peak
of DNA which corresponds with the
diffusion of individual DNA HeLa sees
through solution so it's a got a higher
diffusion time associated with it then
there is this slow relaxation mode which
is a concerted diffusion so we know that
DNA heal season solution at this pH have
a negative charge on them from electro
phoretic mobility and negative charges
have a tendency to kind of repel each
other so as we have a lot of these DNA
he will season solution they're kind of
afraid to do anything because they can't
get too close or too far from anything
because they're surrounded by negative
charges and then analogy I like to use
to kind of conceptualize this is that of
the J so we have here are a couple of
McDonnell Douglas f-18 Hornets so these
Jets I looked this up earlier when you
have one of these as is and it's going
full-throttle these things can go about
1,300 miles per hour but when they're
flying in formation as the Blue Angels
are here I kind of have to slow down a
little bit because if they're going
full-throttle
it's much more difficult for them to
maneuver and control themselves with
respect to their neighbors they can't
get too close or very bad things are
going to happen DNA in solution is very
similar so the mass on mass diffusion of
the DNA is a lot slower and that's what
creates this slow relaxation mode here
and we can see as we add BSA to the
system a few things happen one of which
is this slowmode peak that corresponds
with the diffusion of individual DNA
helixes it shifts to higher relaxation
times that is a slower diffusion of the
molecule in solution so if you go back
and look at this folks Einstein equation
from which these curves are derived
that's most likely a higher mass that's
making us happen and additionally this
the slow mode peak arises from this
intermolecular repulsion of the DNA is
really really really dampened as we have
VSA to the system suggesting that
there's a breakdown in that
intermolecular repulsion and one last
thing I'd like to point out on these
light scattering results is even when we
get above this a saturation finding
saturation of DNA BSA that's added isn't
free you know we don't see this free
translational diffusion tsa here
suggesting at the BSA is still kind of
under the influence of these complexes
as well so I'll quickly recap here we
have DNA we add BSA to it we make
complexes that grow larger the negative
charge on the complex is becomes lesser
and lesser as we add protein to the
system likely through electrostatic
interactions between positively charged
domains on the protein and/or side
chains and as this happens the
electrostatic repulsion between the
complexes breaks down and as we add
protein to the system even above binding
saturation the BSA isn't free and it's
still in loose Association complexes so
what happens when we take these
complexes and absorb them on the surface
this is a set of FTIR spectrum from one
of my adsorption experiments and we can
see that as the complexes absorb the
protein component amid - and my DNA
quantifier is backbone and CC mode you
can see them both clearly with time and
if we look at the composition of the
adsorb material with time at these lower
experimental ratios it's more or less
pretty flat suggesting that the
speciation of the adsorbed material
doesn't exhibit any discrimination and
the complexes are just kind of absorbing
it's a bit of a different situation
though when we move to the highest ratio
used so this is above saturation point
on the binding curve where wherein we
see an early dip in the protein to DNA
ratio of what's absorbed suggesting that
early in the absorption process
kinetically speaking correctly speaking
we have more protein adsorbed to the
surface and with time it kind of
stabilizes but it still results in an
equilibrium protein DNA value that is
disproportionately large and this
suggests to me that maybe we're getting
some early dissociation in these
complexes and the proteins that are
peripherally associated with these
complexes are rapidly absorbing
initially in the process and then
perhaps the complex is without with the
perfectly adsorbed protein will then
adsorb
so we look at the equilibrium results if
we look at the amount of DNA adsorbed as
again given shown by this backbone CC
peak you can see that the amount of DNA
adsorbed as we have protein to this
system actually goes up which is kind of
interesting one way to make more
biomolecules more competition for
surface sites that's not necessarily the
case here now I believe this is a low
tribute wall to the electrostatic
repulsion that is reduced by the
addition of the protein so DNA
adsorption on surfaces is often time is
limited by the actual electrostatic
footprint of the DNA helix because we
know they don't like to get close to
each other they just doesn't like it
they don't like it no one does so when
we take these complexes and we add a BSA
to the system we make them less
repulsive to each other the surface is
able to accommodate more DNA but this
isn't always the case when we move to
the concentrations of BSA that go beyond
what the DNA itself can accommodate we
actually kind of see this sharp drop off
again suggesting to me that maybe those
kinetic results are really onto
something maybe we're getting some
blocking of surface sites by quickly
absorbed protein that's present
preventing complexes from absorbing
beyond that point and one last piece of
result I would like to talk talk about
real quick here is this this chart here
at the bottom showing the peak height of
the Fe o P peak so that is the extent of
direct coordination divided by the CCP
kite so that is the extent of direct
coordination her DNA molecule in the
system as we add BSA to the DNA we see
that the extent with direct coordination
heard zorb DNA goes down so it looks to
me that the BSA somehow is blocking
direct coordination of DNA
phosphodiester groups with the surface
and whether this is through a direct
interaction of the BSA let's say
electrostatically with the
phosphodiester groups or if it's more of
a steric type locking simply
preventing the groups from even touching
the surface is uh I'm not certain yet
but it seems to me that that's what's
going on here creating kind of a protein
bridge between the surface so quickly
wrap this up we see that under the
experimental conditions used BSA in d NH
they do they get very involved with each
other they bind very strongly we can see
that this solution behavior simply as
predicted from the equilibrium binding
behavior it propagates itself in so many
interesting ways in particularly in
solution or you can see the
intermolecular characteristics of the
complexes are going to be altered
greatly by it of the electrostatic
characteristics are influenced greatly
by it and I think perhaps most
importantly for the you know thinking
about soil organic matter and the
behavior of biomolecules in the
environment has a pretty big impact on
what goes on to interface you know the
both the binding mechanism and the
amount of at least the DNA they're
adsorbed is ultra greatly by this
interaction and I think you know if you
guys can remember back to that the
Kleber model that I presented to had the
multi-layer biomolecule formation on the
mineral surface now those guys thought
that you know biomolecules would absorb
and then you'd have another adsorption
event and then another I think this work
kind of demonstrates that's not
necessary in situations where we have
super molecular association it's quite
possible that a multi-layer of material
could form in a single adsorption event
so I'm going to quickly summarize the
bulk of everything and hopefully still
have time to take a few questions
so in our field studies tillage seems to
have a pretty big impact on vom dynamics
so that surface inversion especially on
the downstream processes so my question
I think was a more or less kind of
addressed and that includes both the
amount with diem and also the the
characteristics of DM and looking at the
characteristics in the amount it's
reasonable to assume that yeah sort of
fractionation could be the culprit here
for the removal but there are some
hitches in there that suggests that in
subsoils it might be more source driven
by perhaps more resident microbial
communities or something like that
and if we kind of hone in on this this
region down here we have a lot of
reactive mineral surface area and
microbial products would do some cool
experimental lab studies at the
molecular level we learned quite a few
things there as well you learn that not
only you do biomolecules absorb the
surfaces and change conformation we do
that but it's kind of a continuum it's a
constant energetic struggle these
biomolecules on the surface we see that
at least with the case of ESA I'm
montmorillonite and I suspect some other
proteins as well the pathway with which
that occurs is going to change with
surface coverage and again you know
conformational and actual bonding type
interactions drive a lot of the
associations you see with dirt tight as
well with those mineral surfaces and one
final thing that we see is that when we
combine these biomolecules in solution
they interact in strange ways and they
change the way that the constituents are
retained at the surface so it's kind of
a broad overview of what I just
presented I'd like to quickly wrap up
with some acknowledgments I'd like to
thank my present lab group I'm
particularly my advisor it's been a long
strange ride but she's always giving me
really great advice
Taylor helped me out with getting some
of the dissolve carbon nitrogen data I'm
really thankful for that some past lab
group members when I was still at Penn
State they really kind of helped me
understand the basics would being a grad
student those are super valuable and I
realized that until after the fact so
that they're really great my committee
members I went for or far far too many
other friends and colleagues to
name-drop here I see a lot of you in the
audience I appreciate you showing up my
funding sources obviously and you guys
the audience for being here and I hope I
have time to take a couple quick
questions
[Applause]
my god
if the CDN ratio and dissolved organic
matter in the field is deep is
increasing with depth yes that would
imply that possibly could imply that in
the surface you're getting preferential
absorption high in nitrogen containing
compounds and so then that would then
the expectation will be that microbial
products surely will be lower in the
surface than the subsoil that's right
which was the opposite of unusual right
I think that maybe at least in terms of
the dissolved fraction what is being
shown I think it might be driven more by
microbial processing and byproducts in
the subsoil itself rather than being
transported from above I haven't done
any studies to go beyond that kind of
further but I think that was kind of a
result that my first instinct was the
same as yours you know microbe can be
much more pronounced in this I haven't
done anything you really follow up on
that too much yet unfortunately the
fluorescence as itself isn't super super
strong identifying yes it doesn't
actually change the characteristics that
much so the circular dichroism that I
used to characterize the binding
equilibrium
you can get DNA conformational
information out of that that's kind of
what what and so the Pico is using
looking at the change in a molar
absorptivity of that peak that's a peak
that's associated with the actual B form
of the DNA and didn't seem like it was
being altered further than got higher
and higher because the abstract if 'ti
was increasing so other indicator Peaks
like a a or z form didn't seem to show
up and single-stranded DNA don't absorb
circularly polarized light at all yeah
so that's a feature of the
double-stranded evening that's a really
good question though and and that's
something I wish I had more time to
study I would definitely look further
into those direct interactions that are
going on they're really kind of
understand that morphology a little bit
more specifically with respect to the
proteins I believe that those are
unfolding to some extent once they bind
to those our proteins are made do that
that's a really good question I wish I
had a more definitive answer I mean
based on a circular dichroism I have no
reason to believe it definitely so BSA
is cheap cowboyed it's a byproduct of
slaughterhouses
and these studies use a lot of protein
so I wanted to use something like lah
case or something initially but in order
to kind of you get the kind of
quantities I would need to run these
studies with kind of purity I would need
for a molecular level experiment it
became cost prohibitive very fast but
said there's a whole range of soil
proteins in terms of their
characteristics that includes sizes and
charge characteristics so I think
calling any single one a really great
model I think is unless I'm looking at a
specific process I think it's a little
bit short-sighted here so I just want to
go with something that's real broad
quick and dirty
yeah reviewers when I submit this paper
to the yes and T they were the reviewers
had a very similar set of concerns and I
understand that fully is a fairly common
physical chemical model I think for the
reasons I explained that it's really
cheap it's rarely available I always
joke with people that ask me I say it's
relevant under a dead cow like how is
good diets can release the serum protein
yeah I think a lot of people use it for
very similar reasons and it's so well
studied so I didn't have to for example
the secondary structure I didn't have to
go through a rigorous crystallography
experiment to get that that's already
been really well studied so I was able
to verify my FTIR results with that yeah
so it was passive and kind of
equilibrium German how much is needed is
like actively attributed by biological
processes include by microbes Avellino
molecule kind of working it off
yeah so the accessibility particularly
with respect to DNA is a topic of vast
research interest and it's commonly kind
of understood that mineral surface is to
an extent kind of protect DNA in a lot
of ways from from from microbial
alteration as for the influence of the
processes themselves on the presence of
microbes that's a very good question I
think once the microbes are there and
they're exuding these kind of compounds
that kind of opens up the door for them
being a little more relevant but I think
the general paradigm right now is that
once molecules are adsorbed on services
or some degree of protection there yeah
I guess I probably didn't answer your
question thoroughly but they do they do
so microbes so probably one them they
would love to get their hands on but
they're they're bound these mechanisms I
think you know direct bond formation and
you get actual unfolding which increases
contact points between the biomolecule
and mineral surface I think it just
makes a lot of it really inaccessible as
you know energetically it's tough to get
those off for the same reasons they love
to get on there they're tough to get
back off yeah there's just these vast
releases of Gibbs free energy Oh in the
literature roasting on that and this
makes a lot of sense so I think if we
give
I'll answer your question first I think
super Molecular Association would not
occur when we get further and further
and further away from the isoelectric
point then the molecules become more
electrostatically repulsive to each
other so they're gonna wanna you know
they're less likely to get close that'd
be one situation and situations of high
ionic strength as well things tended
dispersed and unincluded biomolecules so
the local charges that could form that
could be an attractive force might be
disrupted by the presence of more
cations in solution they can disrupt
those things soured those are some of
the situation's I'm thinking of it would
also depend on the identity the
biomolecule
in almost there's a real good clean
answer I would depend a lot on the
identity of cations on the identity of
the biomolecules themselves with super
molecular components within that as far
as the surface behavior is concerned
let's say we were to use calcium and the
DNA study instead I think we probably
see a higher affinity for the surface
well know for DNA specifically because
again the electrostatically
DNA doesn't really want to go near each
other so that's kind of one of the
limiting factors of adsorption on
surfaces we would do something like add
calcium to the system you can kind of
stabilize some of those negative charges
that are on the DNA backbone and there
have been studies of come out of group
in China that have shown that in the
presence of things something like I can
easy on work calcium tends to enhance
the absorption especially with clay
minerals it could be a different story
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu